alternance emploi service civique ou
travaillent à l'étranger le forum des
solutions pour la rentrée au palais des
sports d'elancourt offrait le jeudi 13
octobre de nombreuses opportunités pour
les jeunes idée de les remobiliser et de
leur trouver une solution concrète avec
des partenaires des organismes de
formation la mission locale pendant 3
etc on a cherché par par cet événement a
réuni au même endroit il sera même
créneau horaire des recruteurs
potentiels qui ont aujourd'hui une
réelle
réelle demande une réelle
offre des opportunités dans beauce
chaque année ce sont des milliers de
jeunes qui se retrouvent sans solution
pour la rentrée malheureusement les
choses avaient rencontré d'énormes
difficultés en matière d'emploi en
matière de formation d'accompagnement et
qu'il était vraiment utile de se
développer alors c'est un forum qui
existe depuis trois ans maintenant à la
troisième édition on est ravi de
l'accueillir pour coiffer l'ens cours
mais notre devoir c'est accompagner ces
jeunes qui sont recherche de pointe dans
un climat qui étaient fortement
perturbés et je cherche quoi faire après
mes études parce que j'ai arrêté mais ma
formation qui me plaisait mais c'est
l'école qui me plaisait pas du coup j'ai
arrêté et je trouve quelque chose en
attendant de recommencer au jeu sort
d'un bts professions immobilières j'ai
fait un mois là bas et c'était pas
vraiment ce que je voulais faire et du
coup je cherche je voudrais pas
s'appeler petite enfance et sur place
des informateurs jeunesse plusieurs
entreprises et des écoles ont répondu
présent ils étaient là pour conseiller
accompagner et proposer des postes ou
des formations je présente mes
formations c'est à dire que j'ai deux
formations
dans cyber sécurité qui vont démarrer
notamment à elancourt à la fin du noir
j'ai trouvé ma expliqué du périscolaire
est aussi d
une association garde d'enfants prochain
événement sur l'emploi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sky emploi
fait sa rentrée du 18 au 21 octobre avec
une série d'ateliers de job dating ou
encore de conférence